I can this episode is brought to you by
zapier new sponsor but not new to me as
a service and we'll get to my personal
story but if you run your own business
think about all of the hours and hours
you spend moving information from one
software program to another or one
window to another one social media
platform to another copy and pasting
blah blah blah all because those things
don't easily work together they're not
connected with zapier now they do
automatically my team and I have been
using zapier for years which helps us
with tons of stuff such as just to take
one example connecting Facebook ad
campaigns to our email platform and you
could also as I do
automate publishing things that you put
on Instagram to other social media
platforms saving us hundreds of hours my
team has also raved about zapier support
this is super important to me which in
their words quote is in a class of its
own end quote that is not paid placement
we test all of these things and have
used a peer as full paying retail
customers that is not because we got any
type of freebie so there are tons of
examples now why are there tons of
examples there are tons of examples
because zapier supports more than 1,500
business applications and the
possibilities are virtually endless for
automating processes for getting [ __ ]
done and you may know if you read the
4-hour workweek that the third step is
automation in other words not adding
headcount to a messy process to fix
problems but automating as much as
possible you want to eliminate then
automate and only then delegate and
zapier is one of the best automating
soft wares
you can use the plural one of the best
pieces of automation software I've ever
come across it is the easiest way to
automate a ton of your work so check it
out if you want to try it out or just
learn more go to zapier dot-com slash
Tim that's capi e are calm slash Tim
connect the apps you use the most and
let's a peer take it from there you can
do a million things I'll give one more
example you could for instance instantly
engage with leads for your business send
them to a CRM or spreadsheet and then
notify your team so they can act fast on
every opportunity and here's the really
beautiful part and perhaps the gem to
really highlight it's easy to build an
exact solution that you need in minutes
without writing code or asking a
developer for help so as a non-technical
person you can piece these different
programs together in a way that is
customized for your needs and your
business and what is important to you so
you can get the hell back to focusing on
the stuff that you're good at ok so
that's it
join more than four and a half million
people who are saving an average of 40
hours per month by using zapier now and
for a limited time for my listeners try
zapier for free by going to our special
link zapier comm slash Tim that's Z API
er calm slash Tim for your free 14-day
trial I use this program all the time my
team uses this program all the time zip
your comm slash Tim hey just one thing
Tim this is Michael from zapier it's
pronounced zapier like happier so that's
zapier comm slash tip
this episode is brought to you by super
fat nut butters I've got two boxes of
them actually sit in within 15 feet of
me in a cabinet these little beauties
are great I've been using them as quick
mini breakfasts that's one use and as
on-the-go fuel for a few months now I
was pretty slammed at this afternoon I
had a Wi-Fi debacle and I was preparing
to record a podcast so it didn't have
time to make something to eat or buy
something to eat
but these saved my ass that's a great
use case they're 200 to 300 calories
each depending on which ingredient
cocktail you eat because they're a bunch
of different types MCT meaning medium
chain triglycerides protein macadamia
caffeine etc 3 to 5 grams of net carbs
per pouch their keto and paleo friendly
and they are really easy to transport
you can throw in a backpack or a pocket
I love these things the first time I
tried super fat however be forewarned
I finished the entire box in maybe two
or three days so watch your portion
control and pro tip the way you eat them
you have to unscrew the top you get
about 90% out of it that way and then
you tear the pouch tear it diagonally
not straight across and that'll get you
the last 10% or so I suggest ordering
the variety box you can try that way all
five super fat flavors in one box and
you'll get two pouches of each flavor
that way you can also get 15% off your
order by going to super fat dot-com
slash Tim that's super fat comm slash
Tim for 15% off when you go to one more
time super fat com
slash Tim
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
where it is my job to interview and
attempts to deconstruct world-class
performers to tease out the habits
routines and so on that make them tick
make them good at what they do my guest
this episode is none other than Edward
Norton you can find him on Twitter at
Edward Norton he is one of the most
celebrated actors of his generation and
has starred in produced written or
directed more than 30 films he's been
nominated for three Academy Awards for
his performances his most recent film
motherless Brooklyn which he wrote
directed produced in stars in will be
released on November 1st I've seen it
and I do not say this lightly it is
spectacular it's based on one of my
favorite books and we dig into that and
get into a lot related to creative
process creative struggle and so on in
this episode people mostly know edward
for his acting but he has a substantial
parallel career as an entrepreneur
investor and activist in both technology
and environmental sustainability
ventures he has hit a lot of home runs
we don't cover that in depth in this
episode but we talk about it here and
there as one example in 2010 Norton
co-founded and was chairman of Crowdrise
a charitable crowdfunding platform which
raised more than five hundred million
dollars for US nonprofit organizations
before being acquired by GoFundMe the
largest social fundraising platform in
the world for which Norton now serves on
the board he also co-founded II do which
applies advanced data science and
machine learning to the analysis of
audience engagement signals for the
media and advertising industries IDI
owes data and software are used by every
major film studio in their media
rotation planning and virtually every
major television network now includes II
do data alongside Nielsen data within
their pricing metrics he is the founding
board member of the Masai Wilderness
Conservation Trust an award-winning
Kenyan conservation and community
development organization and in 2010 he
was appointed the first United Nations
goodwill ambassador for biodiversity
Edward really seems to do it all and in
this wide-ranging conversation we
explore
how he does that why he does that why he
feels able to change chapters in his
life we go deep into as I mentioned
creative process creative struggles both
inside and outside of film if you would
like more Edward after this episode you
can listen to my 2016 interview with him
which is very very different at tim vlog
forward slash edward and take my word
for it go check out motherless Brooklyn
in theaters if just for the music alone
it's absolutely outstanding so with that
said without further ado please enjoy a
very wide-ranging and for me super fun
conversation with Edward Norton Edward
welcome back to the show love being here
you know I love our conversations be a
man and we have a lot to talk about and
I want to start with going back in time
to 1999 and this is an interview where
I'm going to ask you questions but I
want to share some autobiographical
sketch from my own life so in 1999 my
mom recommends a book to me and my mom
is I would go so far as to say a book
snob and the best way possible she
recommends me perhaps one book every two
or three years and in the span of two
weeks my brother who is exactly the same
recommends the same book which was
motherless Brooklyn and it became a
favorite book I read it multiple times
and for ages I thought to myself why
hasn't a movie a film adaptation of some
type been made and I want to know how
you came across motherless Brooklyn and
I believe 99 or there abouts and what
impact it had or why it grabbed your
attention sure so I was you know I I let
it was living in New York I was like in
New York actor I started working in
films but I would always split back home
to New York
and it you know I I came up with a lot
of people in theater and people who were
writers and people who were artists and
there's kind of that the thing I love
about New York is the density of it
you're it's not like a company town like
LA right right we're one and I think I
was at a party in the village and
someone I knew who knew Jonathan Lethem
[Music]
got we were talking and and she said you
know Jonathan Lethem and I said sure
sure yeah he's that Brooklyn writer who
you know did this net and she said yeah
he's a friend of mine and you know he's
got this new book coming out about a
Tourette ik detective who has
obsessive-compulsive disorder also and
and he's trying to solve the murder of
his boss in Brooklyn and I literally was
like stop you had me at erotic I was
like I've literally said tourette ik I
was interactive I'm I'm I'm salivating
I'm I'm I have to read it and so I I
somehow got connected to Jonathan and I
I persuaded I got the book in galley
form it hadn't been published yet and
you know revealing our age I it was a it
was a Xerox I had I got a zero a cliff
binder and for those on the podcast who
are young nerdy tech geeks who don't
know what Xerox is before PDF you
actually had to print something on a
paper on a copier and and so I had I had
a paper you know bound xeroxed copy of
it and I read it in one go and you know
it's funny because I when I really think
about why did it grab me so much it's
very similar to the experience I had
reading Catcher in the Rye for the first
time it Lionel the
character in motherless Brooklyn has
many of the same emotional hooks that I
think Holden Caufield does you by the
end of page one you're you're on his
side you know you're sort of because
he's narrating his own story to you
because from the first sentence he's
telling you this is how my head works
and you can hear the calm rational mind
at the center of the story when he
describes this chaotic condition that he
has that that he has to spend his life
navigating you Jonathan Lethem
he pulls off the thing that we all tried
to do in books in art and music which is
the end of page one you're emotionally
bought in you're hooked you relate to
this character you feel for him you have
empathy but you're laughing you're
sympathetic you're impressed it's just
like he does it's a zero to sixty
emotional buy-in that's very very rare
you know you you you relate in in the
most reductive sense you you and then
from there it becomes this this study of
the mind
and how it works and the fact that his
condition is extreme that he has the
physical twitches of Tourette's the the
mental obsessive-compulsive components
of it the vocalizations that are that he
can't control that are both hilarious
and painful and awkward and make life
difficult for him we don't all we don't
all have Tourette's but I think what
Jonathan achieves is everybody sees
themselves in it because we all are
constantly in a conversation with our
own minds we all have a rational Center
that deals with our behavior and our
noisy voices that tell us to do things
we know we don't want to do you know we
we all relate to being essentially in an
argument with ourself and
the impulses that we wish we could
control better so Tourette's is we
Tourette's becomes this this it becomes
it's sort of he and Lionel they become a
proxy for us you know and and our our
the difficulty we have navigating
ourselves and that just nailed me it
just like I was I was completely
entranced by it and honestly as an actor
I just was greedy I was like I want that
gig I want the part know I want I wanna
because because not because it was like
oh this is instantly you know showy it
was more this is just hard how would you
do this you know how do you it presents
all the media Stalin jizz for an actor
it's paradoxical it's actually
physically demanding you have to see the
humanity of the character underneath it
and it just was like this would be a
field day I would really like to play
the role okay so let me hop in for a
second here because I really want to
underscore a few things that you said
that struck me about the book and also
about the film and if if I'm misquoting
you here I'm gonna quote you quoting
someone else but in one one of the
interviews I read and in prep for this
even though we know each other I found
you referencing a CS Lewis line from
Shadowlands we read to know we're not
alone and I think that as you said
Lionel on on one hand is such an unusual
character but on the other is very usual
in that he represents this this schism
that we sometimes feel about our outer
and inner worlds or or perhaps even
dueling inner world right and I'm not
gonna I'm not going to give any spoilers
in this but he then references parts of
himself as Bailey right he has yeah well
and week that we we kept in the film
it's one of the real it's one of the
it's one of the details of the book
that's really marvelous where the
his condition the part of his head that
has the inhibition the lack of
inhibition and impulse control you know
problems and literally fights fights his
his conscious self fights the attempts
to restrain it and and calls him Bailey
so he's it's so it's such a schism that
that when he yells sometimes he the
voice in his head yells at him and names
him Bailey it's it's um you think of you
think about like the ways we talk in our
head like you think about think about
the number of times that you've said
quietly in your head you're such a
[ __ ] idiot like why you know you
think about the critical voice in your
head aimed at yourself it it's literally
right out of you know and you being a
meditator the noisy mind right it's like
the noisy mind literally given given
name given form given voice it's like
it's not just that we can't stop our
thoughts it's that we actually have a
piece of our head that criticizes the
actions that another part of our head is
is you know implementing it's it's
amazing it's an amazing thing that we
live with and that most people don't
discuss as an openly or actively as a
phenomenon you know yeah it's it's it's
also it meaning the film I'll be honest
initially even though I know how skilled
you are I was I was very nervous to see
the advance screening because this book
is so dear to me and it's on top of that
in some ways a very hard film to pull
off and you you you not only pulled it
off and we'll certainly spent some time
on creative process which I want to get
to in a second but you made some
decisions
that I think strengthened the not just
the main characters but the sort of
humanity and the drama and the tension
and everything that goes into the
storyline itself so to to zoom in on
that on the the creative process which I
really know very little about I don't
know the backstory but if we look at
1999 then we jump forward 10 years 2009
10 additional years 2019 when we're
recording this when when did this catch
for you when did it actually start to
happen because you oh I just want to
point out two people wrote produced
directed and starred in this film that's
a lot of concentrated effort so what did
making this film look like it went in
phases and in sum total there's no
question it's the most work I've ever
put into a film it's one of them it's
one of the deepest dives and and longest
climbs how whatever metaphor you want to
use I've I've I've worked on this one
longer and deeper than any creative
piece I've worked on the initial hook as
I said was character I was then busy for
a while
I I had a lot of other projects that I
knew would we're literally going to take
me a couple years before I had the
bandwidth to really seriously
contemplate it but much like you know as
a function of what we're discussing the
brain works on things you you you're
busy doing other things but I was
noodling on it it was rattling around in
my head I would reread the book I would
think about the character I even when I
wasn't actively trying to write it I
even started to sort of like try to
imagine the physicality of it and how do
you take something that's an interior
monologue in a book and reduce it down
and select pieces of it and what are the
best pieces of Lionel and my brain was
kind of cooking on that for years but
when I got
to saying to myself all right actually
what happened was in about 2003 in 2002
sorry I did a run of work I did I did a
big film I did red dragon with a bunch
of great actors and then I did Spike
Lee's the 25th hour and then I did a
play in New York for the rest of the
year I did that Lanford Wilson's burn
this and it was such a the whole the
year was it was an amazing year it was a
it was it was a very notably vital and
satisfying year of creative work for me
I worked with amazing people I worked
with heroes of mine like Spike Lee I did
I did two films in a row with Phil
Hoffman and and then we did play his
next-door to each other and we had come
up together and that was really
gratifying and I I I kind of got to the
end of that year and I felt something
very rare for me which is I sort of felt
satiated I actually felt like I did
spent the whole year working in a gear
that I'd wanted to work in for a long
time and I felt like I'd run a marathon
very successfully and it was sort of
like why run another five miles until it
hurts I feel good I what am I gonna do
do I want to just like keep going until
something goes badly you know and I kind
of got this moment of clarity where I
was like I need to take a break I really
want to take a substantial break and in
2003 I just I stopped working entirely
and I focused on getting my pilot's
license and I I did that for like six or
seven months just trained didn't
aviation training and got my pilot's
license and it was it was great it
really cleared my head it really it
emptied it out and I sort of got to the
end of that and I thought I'm ready to
work on motherless Brooklyn so I I I had
this nice sort of clean slate kind of
feeling and when I sat down to look at
it again I realized there were some
issues with turning it into a film
because it's this very interior
monologue
whole book is kind of this interior
narration and it has a plot but really
it's like Lionel in his head Edward
could I ask you to pause for one sec
yeah you taking that break and we're
gonna come right back to where you
learned off but I would imagine that
there were people who said this is not
the time to take a break you're red hot
this is when you should commit to a B C
D or E
perhaps not but there are many people
who fantasize about taking such a break
but never do they can't shift out of
sixth gear was that hard for you it was
a little bit it was a little bit but I
I've had good examples in my life my you
know my dad is like an incredibly
accomplished person in multiple
dimensions you know he's a scholar and
Marine veteran and a lawyer he was a
corporate litigator he was a US attorney
he was you know federal prosecutor for
Maryland
he was an environmental litigator he was
an environmental organization builder
he's worked at a private equity firm
it's like he's really he's had a
remarkably rich tapestry in his career
there's a connectivity through all of it
there's an intellectual connectivity
there's a values mission driven kind of
thread to everything he's done but I've
really watched my dad over the years
very fearless Lee pulled the video game
cartridge out and put another one in he
really hadn't you remember we were kids
and you had your Atari cartridges I
remember for sure and I got play tanks
or am I gonna play like um you know what
was it combat it was called combat right
or you were you gonna play pong or
whatever he I've seen him have what I
would call the pleasures of staying very
feeling challenged fresh invigorated
about what he was doing through phases
of his adult life and and I kind of
learned to view those changes
as as not as risky but as like
refreshing you know what I mean like I
saw even as a kid you absorb you absorb
when your parent is turned on by what
they're doing you know and I I I
literally remember the new spring in his
step his enthusiasm him being charged up
in it I think as you get older and you
have kids yourself you you forget almost
how important it is how much a child
perceives about whether their parents
are happy you know what I mean it sounds
like most obvious thing in the world but
I I had an awareness that my dad's
happiness was often pegged to making you
know bold shifts in the way he was
spending his time and I I felt like I'm
one of the luckiest people in the world
because I get to work I get to do you
know work or make a livelihood out of
something that is play for me it's it's
and the last thing I wanted to do when I
kind of meditated on it was why do I
want to why do I want to turn this into
a career you know what I mean why would
I turn this into something where it's
exhausting me or it's you know what am i
what am i chasing like if I'm satiated
or if I've just achieved like the things
I wanted to what what a waste it would
be if I if I if I make myself like a
careerist coppertop you know what I mean
right and and and what a waste if I
don't cease while I'm 30 years old on
the freedom to you know the freedom to
that comes with this gig the the freedom
to like get a pilot's license you know
what I mean and those were dreams I had
to I dream my whole life of getting my
pilot's license and I was like I've got
the money now I've got the time what's
my reason for not doing it I don't have
one so
it and then we get back to the voices in
the head cuz voices come in the head
voices of insecurities voices of
competitiveness voices of aspiration
ambition maybe more than aspiration like
ambition - for ongoing plaudits
affirmation applause you know like the
the the hunger for for achievement if
they come in the head and not to mention
that there's the voices from outside but
really the truth is like the ones that
master you are the ones inside they're
the ones that are saying like you know
you're gonna you know you need to get
more of this or and and I think it comes
it comes in
but piloting was really good for me it
was really good to not take a break and
and just kind of like go on vacation or
lounge around because I replaced the
consumption in my work with like the
consumption in learning like in my brain
piloting was like one of the hardest
things I ever took on you know it was
like it made it honestly made the work
I'd been doing feel kind of like play it
play acting which weirdly it is it is
you know like it's like Oh making up
stories and playing dress-up for a
living or like hurling myself into the
sky by myself you know playing with you
know ultimate consequences - screwing it
up you know what I mean it's like it's
like great create creative risk and risk
of watching a landing or that are not
actually equivalent perspective - you
know what I mean because I've always
found I get some of my my best sort of
for me like I get him I think we talked
about this the first time I did your
show I think we talked about like the
things that are meditative that are not
sitting with your legs crossed
clear your mind you know what I mean we
did because we were sitting on a pier
looking at surfers and we're talking
about the role that's played in your
life yeah so Pat you know piloting is a
great meditation for me it absolutely
eradicate s-- everything that the
president moment is very very very
difficult to be out of the present
moment and there's a function in it it's
really interesting which is takeoff and
landing in particular I'm sure there's a
metaphor in this somewhere but taking
off and landing are extremely extremely
focus things even for a modern airline
pilot in a plane that basically flies
itself you are seriously on deck when
you're taking off and landing that plane
and I think that experience is so
intense it's almost like this it almost
does what sometimes it takes me 45
minutes of meditation to get anywhere
near which is it obliterates atomizes
distraction right because you you must
deal with that moment and in which
there's very little margin for error if
something goes wrong and it sort of
atomizes your distraction then you get
yourself up into the sky and you're
floating and somehow that atomization
sustains I don't find myself stressing
once I'm on autopilot and I'm floating
along I looked down at the landscape
going by I think about it's real daniel
kahneman thinking fast thinking slow
like once I'm up in the air and I'm kind
of a head of the plane I get into a very
slow slow gear and a very meditative
gear just watching the landscape go by
and it's wonderful it's like really
really really wonderful for me and I
think it's I get that surfing I get that
scuba diving but it's amazing how
quickly piloting kind of straightens you
out straightens your head out so you you
finished this incredibly productive
sprint
with acting you take this sabbatical of
sorts to focus on piloting which sounds
very therapeutic and holding you in the
present tense for much of the practice
you come out with a clear mind and you
take another look at Marla's Brooklyn
and you're realizing there are some
challenges as you mentioned one of them
translating an internal dialogue in
words on a page into something cinematic
what else what else were you pondering
turning over in your head as you
reexamined motherless Brooklyn cuz it is
not an easy book to turn into a film no
sometimes I think people don't even
realize the degree to which the sound
mix and the music are make-or-break for
a film you can have a film that's cut
the same film that won the Academy Award
for Best Picture with a bad sound mix
will seem like a piece of [ __ ] like it
really it is a Sistani ssin how
important that layer of varnish is on
the whole thing and you you can't adapt
a book into a film a book is not a film
it's just not it functions in the mind
of the reader in a totally different way
because you are activating imagery in
your head in a much much more surreal
way than when you're receiving the
sensory you know being encompassed by me
by visual and sound and a film and you
have to you have to you can't think
about I think faithful adaptations
almost never work if you're trying to
literally transliterate the book into a
verbatim as close to a verbatim thing in
it those are the worst film adaptations
the very best ones I think are literally
like they're like transposing a piano
concerto for guitar you know you have to
just completely change the the wave form
of it and my favorites are ones where
you know like Out of Africa which is a
filmed by a truly great director Cindy
Pollock with one of the great
performances by an actress ever and it
really holds up it really really holds
up when you watch it not only
technically but also fanatically in
terms of being a film about loss and the
desire to hold on to things and possess
them and coming to an acceptance of loss
and impermanence it's a really really
really beautiful film and it's based on
in theory
Isak Dinesen 'he's memoirs out of africa
and shadows on the grass there's none of
the narrative plot that's in the film is
embedded within the book it's her those
are memoirs the whole romance the things
these are all supposition 'el they they
springboarded from the essence of her
sort of spiritual observations and
meditations on impermanence and they
created a story from whole cloth you
know it and that's why it's a great film
they understood what the essence was and
they turned it into a narrative and
cinematic experience that's totally its
own thing and Jonathan Lethem not only
loves films and he's very erudite
he really held holds that belief that
that it's better to springboard and
create something new unto itself so when
I said to him like look we I think you
got a deal with certain structural
challenges in this and one of them is
that motherless Brooklyn has a slightly
surreal tone in the sense that it's
about guys in the modern world who feel
like they're living in a pocket of
Brooklyn that has never moved from 1957
and they speak and act like almost like
Raymond Chandler's gumshoe detectives
but if you slap that onto the screen and
have guys in fedoras talking that way
with Priuses floating by you are you
have you have immediately put yourself
in an ironic mode right you've you
you're essentially saying we're being
tongue-in-cheek here nothing needs to be
taken seriously and if you go in that
gear then Lionel doesn't have to be
taken seriously either
and his Tourette's is now a gag not a
complex person it's it's a
it's a wink-wink kind of a gag because
the rest of the thing is a wink-wink dag
and I didn't want to do motherless
Brooklyn like the Blues Brothers you
know what I mean I didn't which is great
movie that's just you know not what I
thought it had within it
I wanted to play Lionel straight and I
wanted him to be a rich complex
sometimes poignant and affecting and you
know a human being whose loneliness is
real whose isolation is real alongside
his humor and stuff and if you if we
played it ironically that wasn't going
to be there and so I said to Jonathan
like you know in the book people call
him freak show would people really even
do that in 1999 you know what this feels
like is maybe maybe it let's set it in
the hard-boiled world of the books you
love the films we love and you know and
and let it be a 50s thing and amazingly
Jonathan was like I dig that idea you
know he wasn't you know he really was he
wasn't like for one second he you mean
think about that you write a book people
say they love it and then someone comes
along and says hey what if we were to
like transform it like literally set it
in a different time and therefore have
to come up with a different mystery plot
because the book is about the Yakuza and
the Japanese sea urchin trade and Zen
doze and all these things that are
highly contemporary even though there's
an old-school feeling to the noir sort
of vernacular of it and without and he
was like I love it
you know he's like I love it like let's
treat him like Marlow and send Lionel
into another mystery and I and he was
like I get it I think it's a cool idea
and it's very um it I can't really
overstate how rare it is for someone to
be that broad-minded about their own
piece of work you know when did you have
that conversation with him roughly was
that yeah somewhere somewhere like
almost like five years after he
published the book I got it so this
would have been after you've revisited
it after the piloting in a 2004-2005
period
yeah and somewhere honestly somewhere in
flying around over Southern California
trying to do things I had this kind of
clarity that like that this that the way
around what was feeling like a tone
problem was just simply to set it in the
50s and that and once that once that
things sort of settled in me and I knew
Jonathan was okay with it then something
really interesting happened which is
something else that I had been chewing
on for a long time totally unrelated to
mother was Brooklyn was my fascination
with what happened in New York in the
mid 50's this kind of really dark part
of New York's social history that I was
really really interested in and in one
person in particular this guy named
Robert Moses Robert Moses and I had
always thought to myself how do you
approach that how do you approach this
how do you approach the density of what
was going on it's and I and I had
sometimes thought it's kind of like the
way that Chinatown is about stealing la
being built on stolen water I always
thought like what happened in New York
under Robert Moses is sort of its own
original sin it's dark history in the
20th century and but yeah it's too dense
though it's all this urban planning
stuff and blah blah blah and I had this
moment where I suddenly went
that's what Lionel can be the conveyence
into Lionel can we can take Jonathan's
phenomenal detective and we can send him
into in a movie which has to be bigger
has to have finger scope we can send him
into this into this he can become the
conveyance into this very dense and
complex thing that I was also interested
in and suddenly suddenly I had this like
you know this mashup this this idea of
mashing up these two things so Robert
Moses four people we were all its but we
don't need to spend a ton of time
arouses but as I watch
motherless Brooklyn I wondered it had to
be in a way right how could it not be a
Robert Moses incarnate in this film
played by Alec Baldwin and for those who
might have some passing familiarity of
the name Robert Moses is the subject of
a book called the power broker also very
very very good book by Robert Caro and
there's a whole chapter on him too in
the in the Burns documentary called New
York there's a there's a big section
which was that was my first encounter
with the story of Moses was in the new
documentary in New York but yeah he was
and he was he was pitch alertly he was
the parks commissioner but secretly he
was essentially Darth Vader of New York
in the 20th century he held an almost
uncontested imperial power over New York
City above any mayor any governor he he
ran New York City like a like an
autocratic Caesar and made almost all of
the significant decisions about how New
York evolved from being a
nineteenth-century city into being a
modern city he the the the whole
physical landscape of New York's
transformation in that era was directed
by him this is speaking of directing as
I mentioned earlier you you wrote
produced directed and starred in this
film did you want to do from the outset
all of those things or was that a
byproduct of challenges you ran into or
is there some other origin story I'm
just wondering how it came together it
no directing I wanted to like I said I'm
not really totally joking I was kind of
it was a greedy actor impulse to grab a
great role I really thought this is a
really memorable character and it's a
great challenge it's everything I love
to try to take on and it was like I just
want to play this part then I did
I was turned on by the challenge of
adapting it and then I ran into that
went through this process that we've
talked about and when suddenly I kind of
had this what was for me exciting idea
about the mash-up and I had Jonathan's
Hall Pass to be that sort of
freewheeling in it I spent a lot of time
then researching and working on how to
make kind of a literary mashup not
between books but really just of
motherless Brooklyn but conveying it
into the sort of a literary version of
this history and and once I was finished
that which took me a long time like many
a number of years because I went through
writer's block and I when I got hung up
on the plotting and I got distracted by
other projects but when I finally got it
done took a solid eight years I would
say for me to get to where I was happy
with it then I reached a point where I
was in my own mind gonna shop it around
to directors that I admired but someone
you know did something good for me the
studio executive that I was friends with
actually sat me down in a bar in New
York on 12th Street it was like dude you
need to direct this and I was sort of
like uh-huh but the part is really
challenging and and and he literally
said to me look think about the movies
that we came up on that mattered to us
do the right thing
Reds Warren Beatty's great film about
American socialists you know Dances with
Wolves and Unforgiven like be kept
citing all these examples of like
sometimes an actor is really right for a
role it's really in their wheelhouse and
they've come up with a story and they
just do it you know they take that big
swing and and he was like he kind of
said to me like what you know why
wouldn't you do this like why wouldn't
you you've just mash up his yours you
don't want to sit over someone's
shoulder
you know and he just was like you can do
this and I kind of did have that moment
where I went mmm you know what yeah why
wouldn't I
I do love those films they have meant a
lot to me like some of some of them were
defining films for me and it was sort of
like I he urged me across the line into
the into getting excited about just
owning it you know and when if if we're
I don't mean to obsess on the timeline
but I'm so curious to get an idea of the
timeline since this is such a
longitudinal project right I mean it's
so when when did you have that meeting
with this executive who gave you the
talking to relate to directing the film
roughly so if I was because normally I
started a jumpring but but normally what
happens to me and I'm sure has happened
to a lot of people is they have this
backburner set of projects but by and
large in my case I never come back to
them so I'm I'm fascinated by someone as
busy as you are and certainly not just
with film you have you have many many
hats that you wear much like your dad in
a sense very multifaceted how this
remained a project roughly when did you
have this conversation I probably
started
I'm actually not probably I started
actively writing it the summer of 2003
and I wrote like 60 or 70 pages of what
became like 150 page script and they
were good like they were good they were
the beginning of the movie as it is now
and and people really liked it like they
were like this is really really cool
like and then I got horribly blocked I
got it wasn't like distracted nasai
really I had it framed out and I had
things but I couldn't in my mind just
sort of puzzle out a compelling way to
get lost in the murk but emerge from it
you know what I mean because I do
especially with this just if I could
call it genre right is the the the
getting lost in the Merc is
importantly you know you you anybody who
watches chinatown and tells me the the
first time that they they have any idea
what's going on until about 20 minutes
before the end of the movie is lying you
have no idea what's going on in that
movie zero in fact I've tracked it
there's a very specific scene where he's
in the car with Faye Dunaway where he
finally married his read of what he
thinks is going on and there's only
about 20 minutes left in the movie and
by the way he's wrong
he he he thinks that what's going on is
all about the water and of course it's
about incest
right and and that you know with these
films that it's not about comprehension
that getting lost in deep convolution is
actually part of the point which is
which is an important point which is
that it's hard to know what's taking
place around you
it literally existentially noir at its
best is about how difficult it is to see
where the dangers are around you and
where power is and who's got the power
you know that that's that's in what
their fanatical II I think is their
strength is they really do remind us
there are things going on in the shadows
that are that are antagonistic to us and
that if we don't figure out what's going
on damage is gonna get done you know but
but I I wanted I wanted the puzzle to
make sense even you know you have to get
lost but you have to know underneath it
what's really going on so that you can
emerge from it or bring people out of it
in a way that is it all is satisfying
and it does make sense in the end you
know to some degree and so I got hung up
and then I did that terrible thing which
is I put it in the drawer right here the
point I did I put it in the drawer and I
was like I just need a break and then
literally I got sent to a really weird
cool script called down in the valley
and I decided I'm gonna
do that I'll do it quick I wasn't gonna
do that really quick it's a little
independent film and do that one quick
and then I'll come right back to this
right and then then I did the
illusionist and then nana film I had
been working on for years to pull
together came together The Painted Veil
Naomi Watts got free and she wanted to
do it and suddenly it was like I'm
making a film for six months in Prague
and then I'm making a film for six
months in China and time just starts to
roll by and your mind gets further and
further from the thing you're working on
and it's just one thing after another
kept coming in and then that thing in
the drawer that you haven't figured out
becomes more and more and more of a
block you know of lead it's just like
it's not an active thing and I think the
same person who later helped me embraced
it I should direct it at a certain point
called me and was like hey there's other
people who were interested in this I
think maybe um you know should we let
someone else take a crack at it and I
don't even know if that was true I have
a feeling might have just been sticking
a fork in me but it worked like actually
he was the studio executive who at that
time was running new line and he
actually did something that I laugh at
in retrospect which is he cited a
specific director to me who I think he
knew the idea of giving up my project
have that person specifically was gonna
make my skin crawl like and and he and
he just whether it was conscious or not
he he hit me with exactly the right
piece of information for my result to
get very very strong again and I I took
it out and and he he did kind of put a
deadline on me he was like look you know
we we've been sitting on this thing a
long time and this person wants to do it
and I was like no no no no no no no no
no no no no no and he was like how about
we just agree how about we just agree
like you'll get it done by Christmas or
we'll start having a real conversation
about like letting someone else take a
crack at it
and it was it was great it I literally
knuckled down and I pulled it out I
looked at it I talked to some other
writers with some focus who I respect
puzzled it out cracked it and finished
it really aggressively really I wrote
like I wrote my college thesis I wrote
the large bulk of the rest of it in like
two or three weeks of like long deep
nights of just powering it through and
then it was done very very helpful
friend the anonymous executive no it's
not anonymous Toby a Marquis their head
Warner Brothers now he's very very
clever maybe accidentally but very
helpful clever helpful but also like you
know Hollywood and the business of
movies is sort of like inside baseball
and honestly I sometimes think it's
probably very boring to most people but
I I do think I do think it's work it's
always good to highlight when when
there's exceptions to sort of the the
reductive cliche about something and
people in this day and age are
constantly talking about how Studios you
know it's impossible to get original
adult stuff made and everything but I
did not I've had this champion toby
Emmerich's been this incredible stalwart
champion of my project for over a decade
like a really long time encouraging me
pushing me along helping me actually
like get through these mental block
moments and then when I actually got it
done starting to try to figure out with
me how to get it made and he didn't have
the collateral to get it made and then
we went through this next period which
was like five years of really struggling
to to you know it was like the produce
oriole struggle the writer struggle was
over but the produce oriole struggle was
at least five years of both of us
hammering on it and trying every
equation of casting and financing and
everything to get it made and all you
know thwarted throughout we were
constantly thwarted let's let's dig into
the wort for a second here because I
would imagine that many people listening
on some level or thinking you're Edward
freakin Norton like why on earth would
you hit these roadblocks so what what
what we're the types of feedback or the
the pushback that you experienced and
I'm not saying that I doubt you had it I
just think it'd be helpful know and I'm
curious to hear more about honestly I
think no one can ever take for granted
that someone should just hand you money
to make a film I never know it
like I don't it doesn't matter if you've
been nominated for 10 Academy Awards or
it it doesn't matter it's risky it's
risky and when someone's coming at you
if I'm gonna do a big scale 1950s period
film about like a dense kind of the
Chinatown like story about New York City
and its urban development oh and at the
middle of it is a guy with Tourette
syndrome and obsessive-compulsive
disorder it's sort of you know Rain Man
meats Chinatown people's eyes just
because the eyes start crossing and you
go okay not Chinatown LA Confidential
that one was much more accessible it's
you know what it is it's not Rain Man
he's he's got full-on autism it's
Forrest Gump meets LA Confidential meets
LA Confidential the more accessible
version of both things but people's eyes
are just like you got your chocolate in
my peanut butter my peanut butter in
your choc they don't they're like what
the hell are you talking about like you
know it's really you're you're
definitely like describing something in
the trade it's like just to say that its
execution dependent is a is a is an
understatement mostly people are like
you know please bring us the next one
you know what I mean like it's and and
when you're saying to people will you
give us me tens of millions of dollars
to make this you you can't like walk
around in a huff like how can this be so
tough like I understood why it was tough
I understood why it was why was
and also like you know I the upsides of
not pursuing let's call it a careerist
you know pursuing projects where my
agenda was will this be one of the
biggest movies ever is that you can make
a lot of really excellent films that
you're proud of and that people end up
not only loving but seeing is maybe
almost like essential zeitgeist II
movies like Fight Club or 25th hour or
American Sri X but those none of those
movies were financially successful so
it's not like I was walking around like
you know like like some actor on a run
of gigantic hits who's considered like
you know oh this guy's gonna open the
movie at 20 million so we'll do anything
he wants to do you know what I mean it's
just it's just not the same and you
can't unfortunately you you can't you
can't collateralize artistic credibility
into any kind of a you know any any
number you just can't you know you can
you can do it in some measure and if I'd
been willing to make if I'd been able to
make motherless Brooklyn the way I
wanted to for 15 million bucks of budget
I could I could have done it the next
day you know I didn't mean but I needed
slightly more than that and so it was
tricky it was just tricky that may but I
want to continue on the on the hunt for
producers and production budget but may
I ask you a question about writing
process yeah see you pull out this dusty
bound pile of paper that's been sitting
in your desk
what is the first day of writing look
like I mean do you just start spitting
out anything that comes to mind and
hopes that something good lands on the
page or do you use a different strategy
I mean I as someone who's put stuff on
the shelf and I find writing very very
difficult medium and so if I if I let
something sit for a long time I might be
able to go
I can edit what I've done very quickly
but the thing that struck fear in my
heart that murky part that I couldn't
quite find my way through may have been
turned into a mountain in the mean time
right like it's it's I've developed all
these stories around why it was hard how
hard it was what did the first day or
the first few days of working on that
look like and feel like for you well the
really interesting thing was that when I
read what I had written I forgot some of
what I had written and I liked it like I
was reading it as if someone else had
written it and it was making me laugh
you know I was I had this reinvigoration
of the pleasure of it ironically because
procrastination does a really weird
thing to your head you know when you
when you push something off it starts to
become monolithic you know I definitely
I don't know what that is but it it
becomes monolithic and you and then it
just intensifies your desire to avoid it
and it was fat it was it was fascinating
to read it and find and kind of have the
sensation of like this is this is so
much fun like this is such fun language
the character circle why they'd have put
it you know
why had to give up on this and then in a
funny way I went back to my cards
because my issue wasn't a character
issue it wasn't a language it was just a
plotting issue and I looked at my cards
cards you mean literally index cards for
seasons totally yeah and I and I sat
down on a huge rug and I mapped them all
out and I kind of looked at the node
that was like this was a problem and
like I said I I had a couple
conversations I brought some people in
that I trust and I was like really I'm
hung up on this whole thing over this I
did kind of almost just some Rubik's
Cube in with some people and it was like
I was like oh wait a second I'm
overthinking this this gets easily
solved by just doing X right and then
suddenly it was like holy crap like that
really wasn't that big a deal at all I
just needed you know I needed a few P
in a room brainstorming and I did it
with some Brian Koppelman and David Lee
oh nice ooh
you know great pals great writers wrote
rounders produce The Illusionist
and it was kind of like it was kind of
like you know I ran it them through it
there they're obviously terrific on this
stuff and really just they they let me
use them as a sounding board i three
ideas around I feel like I remembered
David Levine saying at some point like I
said something and David Lee goes out
wait what's wrong with that
he was like you just said it like what's
wrong with it like what's wrong with
that that's great you know and I was
kind of like oh that's you know is it
that simple you know and then and and it
was like it was they helped me they
helped me you know crack my own my own
blockage anyway such good guys just just
to take a second for that there's
they're two really skilled and really
really just good human beings also
co-creators along with Andrew Ross
Sorkin of Billy billions yeah yeah
that's their their show and they're
they're great those guys some they
they're like serious tradecraft pros you
know they really are like they they're
writers in the old school mode you know
they and and they were great helped me
so they helped me punch through it and
then I went and like I said I wrote the
rest of it in kind of almost like a
blitz and and it was great you know it's
a funny thing like I was actually
thinking about as we've been talking
about this sometimes I think guys don't
acknowledge men especially maybe women
experienced this too I don't I don't
know I certainly see it in a lot of my
guy friends isn't like it's so stupid to
be competitive about some things but but
in what we've been talking about I can
actually kind of recognize if I'm honest
that two things happened one is that
when Toby at one point said to me I'm
gonna I'm gonna give someone else a
crack at this it really was actually
like the flaring of a very like you know
low a very low kind of primitive kind of
competitive and grow sensation in me
that galvanized me you know I kind of
was like you're not giving it to that
guy no no way
no way like this is mine and then I'm
gonna like give me a you know it was
like it did kind of push me right and
that's not necessarily like a quality
that that that's a quality I would say
in general that I try to deep
de-emphasize or or cultivate out of
myself like like competitive competitive
a competitive attitude within creative
work it's really stupid and I think it
can be really counterproductive I also
think like around the culture of movies
with award shows and all this [ __ ]
there's so much absurd like like
construct of competitiveness that is
beyond inauthentic to anything to do
with this kind of work you know what I
mean it's like it's like it's even more
inauthentic to creative work and it
isn't figure skating you know where it's
like subjectively scoring figure skating
routine it's like the idea that the idea
that that the culture would construct
like a competitive matrix around any
kind of a creative form with awards and
all this stuff is really like sort of
mortifying you know in some ways and I
think but at the same time like it it
galvanized me and it's funny because we
were talking about we talked about
flying dick there's an inch
same kind of component of that too which
is say like oh well your insecurities
come in I'm not working and you know are
people gonna forget about me just stupid
stuff comes in your head but there's an
interesting thing about doing something
like getting good at flying or getting
good at surfing which is like it drops
through you into this kind of confidence
and there's a component of that that's
competitive too because in a weird way
you go in your head as a guy I think
something you sort of go yeah but I can
do this right it's like having a black
belt it's sort of like it's like you're
listening to someone blather on about
something and in the back of your head
going can you take off a plane and land
it you know what I mean it's like
serious yeah I get it I get it I totally
get it you know again not the highest
order of motivation but it it when you
say like a lot of people don't do that
or a lot of people wouldn't take that
break sometimes I think if what you're
doing is you're sort of I don't know
exercising your muscles or developing a
musculature that you're proud of right
if it's a if it's like a component of
yourself that you it's almost like you
have a secret you have some secret skill
or you have a thing it it's interesting
the way that it it's interesting the way
that it it dials down the volume on on
insecurities in general you know what I
mean I do yeah a bit I mean it's really
hinges it seems to me on the stories you
tell yourself which create the lenses of
your reality in the sense that they they
mold your perception of what you're
doing yeah and don't don't you I mean
have you've done so like when you
famously like with the with the you know
when you like word and worked on
kickboxing right yeah many things or
when you do any of the things you've
done to sort of demonstrate that with
that you can do things within body
transformation or learning dispute or
anything right
don't don't you on some net level come
away with it
come away
it's saying you know I have a capability
now that that I carry within me whether
other people see it or not
that gives me like a kind of a
confidence 100 percent 100 percent which
is why I often recommend to people even
if they never have the opportunity
hopefully never have the opportunity to
use kickboxing or Brazilian jiu-jitsu or
some martial art outside of a practice
environment that they should train
because the way they will carry
themselves through the world male/female
doesn't matter age doesn't matter will
be different and there will be a certain
quiet confidence that I think can be
built and added to with many different
skills that demonstrate an ability
demonstrate to yourself an ability to
learn be self-sufficient survive but
whatever it might be so it makes perfect
sense to me and also the the motivation
that you're talking about are the
motivations be they good or bad
somewhere in between putting aside the
value judgement they are meaning they
exist and in in the examples that you've
a few of the examples you've given
you've been able to utilize them right
harness them ultimately to it for this
one example get the script done right so
it's it's it's a it's it's I was I was
listening to someone not long ago talk
about how they've shifted from looking
at things on a value scale of good to
bad as an experiment to one of beautiful
or not beautiful like how can you take
whatever this motivation is whatever
this opportunity is and turn it into
something beautiful it doesn't mean you
you ignore morality or good or bad but
but as a thought experiment looking at
things through that lens
so you're able to take what might be
looked at as a base primitive urge this
drive and transmute it into oddly enough
I mean at the end product like something
that looks very deeply at impulses and
human nature yes I I also think I don't
know there's there's some frustration at
not being able to achieve some some goal
is never Pleasant right we don't
associate it it's just not a pleasant
feeling because you sort of want what
you want and especially if you think
you've got ha you know high-minded or
only positive motivations you're sort of
like mmm it's frustrating not to get to
do this and with this project I
definitely you know there was a period
where it was it was always hovering it
was it had a kind of an albatross II
kind of effect on me in the sense that
it was I wanted to do it and I felt I
had a good vision for it and that it
could be unique and and and actually
like be the kind of hypnotic movie
experience that really reminds people
this is why we go to movies you know
what I mean
and I really had all that conviction but
then I was I was like bending my life
it was like it was like this shadow
force it was like a Dark Matter force in
my life because it had this
gravitational pull that would it it
would affect my decisions you know I
would sort of go well you know I could
take another year off or you're gonna
point you know where you don't have kids
and you're in a great new relationship
and you say oh well let's just take our
surfboards and go but it's like oh but
this might you know I got to keep
pressing on this because it might happen
this year and it sort of it throws like
like those old models of the universe
where the black hole is you know
taking the time-space fabric and bending
it you know that's how this was for me
it was it was like bending the
space-time fabric of my life even though
it was not happening and it and it and
there's this point where you you have to
kind of keep reassessing it's like how
long am I gonna like let this Mirage is
this a mirage or is it a thing that I
just have to persevere and how long am I
gonna chase the Mirage you know and and
when you were shopping I'm not sure if
that's the right term but when you were
engaging in the produce Oriole as a the
word challenges and pursuing that at
that point were you confident that you
could get it made and that it was going
to get made or was it more of a test run
to see or a fishing trip to see what
type of feedback you would get how could
I guess how at that point how convinced
were you it would happen or how
committed were you to sort of willing it
to happen I I had many moments where I
thought this this is not gonna work out
the way I want it to I I just don't have
I don't have the cards to win this hand
I'm I'm and I went through I went
through a couple things where I was like
well maybe I will just direct this now
and go to another actor you know who I
think we get this movie made instantly
and I think would be really great you
know but that kind of broke my heart a
little bit selfishly I really felt
connected to this character of Lionel
and I could kind of see my way into that
but I just I just couldn't bite the
bullet and make those phone calls you
know I had a moment of this all went on
so long that you know Netflix became
a big force in in the landscape of ways
you could get this stuff done and I
could have walked over to those guys who
I think are awesome and I think gotten
this done in in probably one
conversation and I didn't have I wasn't
negative on that I it was probably the
thing I would have but I had but I had a
note it was before they had really
started making some commitments to
putting things in the theater the way
they did with Roma the way they did are
doing with Noah Baumbach terrific movie
marriage story and others you know and
and I I didn't want to get hung up on
sort of the like almost like the
pretension of saying I want to see this
in the theater but I did I just I I
wasn't quite willing at that point to
surrender to the idea of of making it
only for a streaming presentation you
know like they did with Romo I'd have
done it in a heartbeat you know like and
I think it's I'm not one of the ones
who's negative on the way they're
approaching this stuff I think it's
really I think there's a lot of really
really new and diverse voices are
getting a platform to tell stories
because of their model you know so I but
it was a timing thing and I felt very
low about it at times yeah very very not
defeated but just very discouraged and
thought that it might be one of those
things I just I just had to sort of sigh
and make a big pivot on or let go of and
then a you know a weird set of things
started becoming emergent to me post
2016 Toby Emmerich became a head of
Warner and he said to me like look I'm
not gonna have this job and not make a
couple movies I would I really want to
make and it's Warner Brothers and we've
got to make those movies that's that's
part of
tradition and yours is one of the ones I
want to get done and I'm gonna figure
out the absolute best deal I can give
you to get it done and you're gonna have
to find some of the money or a lot of
the money but we're gonna I will create
a way that we can get this done which is
amazing no no no his his there's a lot
of people who have that job who don't
have you don't say now that I've got
this job I'm not gonna tighten up you
know I didn't mean I'm not gonna play to
be her forever I'm just gonna I'm gonna
use the position to do some of the
things that made me want to get into
this in the first place and he did
immediately he did with Bradley Cooper
on Stars born
and he did it with me you know he was
like I'm he literally said like part of
the tradition at Warner Brothers is we
make like you know auteur driven stuff
and all Clint Eastwood's films were done
there and they made LA Confidential and
you know and so that was a shift and
then also I got Bruce Willis stepped in
and stepped up for the movie and that
made a difference and I found I called
in a lot of chips and figured out some
very clever ways to pull together the
co-financing alongside Warner Brothers
that we needed and and suddenly started
to tumble I have to and yeah go ahead
yeah I have a follow-up question there's
a post post 2016 you've seen the film
and even though I had written it
essentially the way it is by 2012 there
was a lot about what changed after 2016
that suddenly you know Toby was ringing
me up and saying man a lot of what is
embedded in this script is is
staggeringly on point right now in a way
that it was not in 2014 and um and I
think that maybe that was part of why
when I was giving it to all these
terrific actors and saying I don't have
any money for this I have to have
everybody like you know defer fees and
just work for love of the project
but it felt to the--to people it felt
like of its moment more than it had a
few years before and and I think it it
exerted more of a gravitational pull on
this incredible cast of actors and that
helped me get it made - you have an
incredibly star-studded cast you have in
front of the camera you also have I did
a fair amount of research prior to our
conversation you also have a lot of
talent behind the cameras and working on
the film and other capacities who are
involved you talked about deferring fees
or having actors willing to defer
payment in some fashion you used if I
think the phrase creative co-financing
or found creative ways to co-financed
into my life you feel free to not answer
if if that's the best move but could you
give even a hint as to what that means
what bit because you can never you
really can't hedge off the risk of an
individual film the only way you can do
that is if like the way that Steven
Soderbergh and I'm and Channing Tatum
really brilliantly with Magic Mike
realized like we can make this film for
like under six million bucks and we can
pre-sell the foreign for more than the
budget and then we can own it you know
what I mean so like we can we can start
shooting the film knowing that we're in
the black on it and therefore literally
financed it ourselves and own it that
you can you can hedge off you can
literally de-risk a film if you can make
it for less than what you can pre-sell
the foreign on that's the only way to to
literally we hedge off all risk on a
single film right which is why like most
Co financing companies are the ones with
big bank roles like legendary that can
do big slate financing with the studio
because you're essentially playing the
portfolio right and historically studio
returns have delivered a return like a
positive return
right so if you're going to people and
saying hey we put some money in my film
you can talk till you're blue in the
face about why it's gonna work but the
bottom line is the numbers don't lie you
you you're taking just a massive
singular risk if you invest in one film
right but I I did a deal with some of my
co-financier around basically I had
access to the secondary trading on a
company a technology company that I was
an original investor in and strategic
advisor to and um I I had a fund a
little boutique fund that was doing
secondary trading in that company and um
and I and I basically set up a situation
where some of the investors in my film
had been looking at acquiring that
company through their private equity
firm and I I they couldn't but I I was
able to essentially do a deal with where
they could be my LPS and buy buy a stake
through secondary a secondary deal in
this company that they were very
interested in and we all felt that the
we all felt that the likely returns on
that were such a shirt saying that that
they considered it I basically told him
I'll get you access to this deal if
you'll finance my film too and so I set
up like a pair trade I set up sort of
like I can a pair trade on my film and a
position in this company this is also a
great example of where swapping
cartridges in the the video game that is
the timeline of your multifaceted career
paid off in a really tangible way right
because you've been exercising other
interests and developing other
capabilities and knowledge and it
seemingly completely unrelated
that then allowed you in some ways to
get done a project in what many people
would view is your primary career over a
period of 20 years to finally get it
done that's yeah that's remarkable
there's no question that my kind of
parallel life outside of my creative
filmmaking life this whole other
dimension of my professional life that
is you know it's not a public-facing
component of my life 100% the that that
ended up unlocking the way to to get
this passion project done
there's no no doubt about it yeah Wow
and I I think I can say that no film no
film has ever been financed off of the
specific type of deal that we did for
this one though
and I don't and I will know it's not
replicable either for me
it was a very very very unique situation
and I I I wouldn't even want to go
through the headache of trying to
replicate what we did on this because I
think it was a little bit like Alex
Honnold
I felt like I was I felt like I was
going up a pitch without a rope and that
if I didn't get each and every handhold
perfect it was gonna come it was gonna
be a complete and utter you know it was
gonna be a complete fail like like it
was sort of like III was either gonna
get to the top or the whole thing was
gonna crash and burn completely there
was no there really was not and they
were between yeah there was really
wasn't it in between it was like it was
like and the bet paid off in every way
and and the beautiful thing about it was
actually in a funny way the
the Alliance's I formed with people to
get this done are stick now you know
that it's like I really feel I really
feel like a deep kind of alliance with
the people who help me achieve this this
long-held dream and it's been I've been
able to reciprocate there have been
ripple effects to finally getting it
done that were there were as as
meaningful as as the thing itself which
is great how cool the
the tour of duty that was put in to get
it made is no joke and you mentioned
theatrical run and putting the film into
theaters and I I could make an argument
and I texted you this right after I saw
the film that if even if the projector
ceased to work and one were only able to
listen to the movie through a proper
sound system like some of the sound
systems and theaters that it would be
worth much more than the cost of
admission
could you speak to the the soundtrack in
the music and anything that that you
think makes it noteworthy because I am
NOT an audiophile and not a musician I
appreciate music I enjoy it but I don't
know the first thing about music theory
or sound quality or anything like that
and yet the the audio experience was so
different for this film compared to the
last let's just call it dozen films I've
seen in theaters why is that well I
think that I think that music and sound
in many films is approached as what I
would call an emotional accelerator or
just an emotional enhancement of what is
already taking place within the text so
the moment is obviously dramatic and the
music reflects that drama it's violent
and the music reflects the violence it's
it's sad and the music reflects the
sadness right and and sometimes you get
what I would call a very reductive kind
of mirroring effect and and what that
does I think is it makes the music
disappear right it makes the music
become a pad of embellishment underneath
the other aspects of the film as opposed
to like a unique a unique element in its
own right that is almost taking on a
primary role in communicating emotion or
character or narrative or whatever right
and I think a lot of my favorite films
have I think not even mine
everybody's favorite films you usually
have music that's more transcendent and
that anomie transcendent literally that
is transcends the text it's not it's not
solely there as kind of a subtle
embellishment it's it's both it's kind
of more boldly used as its as its own
primary piece of the experience of the
hypnosis that the film's working on you
and I you know jazz was gonna be a part
of this film because of the era it was
also to me if there's a if there's a
kind of music that's tourette ik it's
jazz in the Harriet retic type of music
not just in it's like sort of explosive
sort of but because literally it's about
taking melodic forms and twisting them
round and round and round and doing
variations on a melody variations on a
melody variations on a melody and and so
I knew anyone wanted out a little bit
and once and on the jazz component of it
i I went initially to basically a genius
went went Marsalis who helped me curate
and think
[Music]
some of the key music that was being
played in a club in the film but I also
wanted to weave in I wanted to weave in
on free I don't know why I was so into
mashups on this mashup so it's sort of
like you know at erratic at erratic
character with a old-fashioned noir
I wanted to mash up sort of jazz with
Radiohead in a way the things I loved
and I got Thom Yorke to write a
beautiful song for the film that we that
we work into the film not only in his
performance of it but also in a 50s
style Miles Davis like arrangement of it
and again it was one of those things
that a lot of people kind of looked at
me a little bit cross-eyed they were
like this you you can't you know it's
gonna be it's it's gonna feel weird to
bring his voicing into a film in that
era or to try to bring a modernist
sensibility of AB dissonance and
electronic kind of components into a
jazz score but I didn't think that was
true because I knew that Tom really like
has an appreciation of jazz especially
like mint Charles Mingus and
other jazz artists who explored the kind
of dissonance that I think Tom has
explored in his own music on records
like kid a and amnesiac and his own solo
stuff and I knew there was more synergy
than people were recognizing on paper
and I thought we can do something really
interesting
mashing these things up and and we did
and I think it's this trifecta of Tom
and went Marsalis and this incredible
incredible young composer in London
named Daniel Pemberton and everybody's
been reacting to it and I I agree with
you I did I've been working on this for
like a number of years and I am still
not tired of listening to the music on
the film I I have the the soundtrack
gate actually the soundtrack just came
out these
past Friday we released the soundtrack
and the score last week on the streaming
services and smart there's wonderful
there they are just they you can listen
to them without having seen a frame of
the film and it is really really
beautiful stuff really beautiful stuff
kudos for the dance scene as well I'm up
we don't have to give any spoilers but
what a what a fantastic fantastic scene
people who watch it will know what I'm
referring to
and I want to hop to a reference to I
dare call it a review but I don't think
review is quite the right word so I've
had Ken Burns on this podcast he's one
of the people who don't recognize the
names or the name one of the most
legendary if not the most legendary
well-respected documentarian of ever
possibly in the United States it means
just a prolific prodigious talent and he
wrote a piece I mean I would say I would
say he bent the genre I'd say there's a
there's a redefine the genre I think
there was never there was never
long-form you know you could even argue
that the whole the whole embrace of
long-form storytelling that's now
ubiquitous on net worth at what we call
binge TV watching started with the Civil
War you know what I mean Ken's
film the Civil War was the most
audacious long-form film in American
history at that time and and he
basically said he was one of the first
people to say people will not only sit
for this they will devour it they want
rich nuanced long stories about these
seminal events in our history that are
still defining who we are you know and
and he he reinvigorated reshaped the
entire form of of not just documentary
but I literally think of filmed
storytelling he did he has he has and
I'll probably get some of these numbers
wrong but since since we're just doing
a quick deep dive on Ken there are there
are film effects named after Ken Burns
mostly related to his treatment of still
photographs with embedded within and
named after him in some of those popular
software programs currently being used
and the Civil War one must keep in mind
was on broadcast television and it was
somewhere between 14 and 20 hours of
total content and at the time I want to
say within a year or so between 30 and
40 million people had watched the Civil
War I mean and if you if just let that
sink in for a second
considering that its appointment viewing
I mean it's it's absolutely incredible
so he writes this piece on medium which
I which I only very recently read and
I'm gonna read the last paragraph I mean
it's it's it's absolutely worth reading
and I'll link to it in the show notes
for people at Tim da blog for such
podcast and you can find Edward just
search norton or Edward Norton and then
we'll have a link to this but the last
paragraph is is one that really strikes
me so if a lonely orphan burdened by
society's heartless response to his
Tourette's syndrome can rise above his
daily struggles and battle against jaded
masters of the universe types then what
excuse to the rest of us have for our
own apathy motherless Brooklyn answers
with a resounding none exclamation point
that's a hell of an ending to a hell of
a peace about the film about you about
society also we could talk about that
but the question I'd love to hear your
thoughts on eventually is what would you
hope this film to do what what effect if
any do you want it to have on people or
the the sort of larger larger picture if
any just so curious what what you'd like
the impact to be on individuals who
watch it or otherwise well I think to
stick with Ken for I mean Ken's Ken's
affirmation of the film was just like it
was about as meaningful a compliment as
I've ever gotten
on my own work it's like he's he's he's
one of the Druids in in my you know in
my matrix of people who have really
mattered in in filmmaking he's he's one
of the Giants and he and he also in
particular he has clearly got this
unparalleled commitment to dissecting
kind of the American character you know
he he really he's committed his whole
creative career to the to trying to
understand who we are through the past
and and it's I I can't you know I I I
can't overstate my admiration for the
work he's done so it's it's to have him
kind of actually take the time to write
this piece that he wrote about the film
was was a you know I I had tears in my
eyes when I read it the first time
cannot I'll just pause for a quick
second I'm sorry because people may not
realize just how a few Civ and direct
his commentary is in this piece of it
I've never seen anything like it so I'll
just give one more quote which is dot
dot dot so I'm not going to read the the
the entire paragraph but an instantly
classic lead character in a career best
performance by one of our finest actors
scene after CNF memorably smart and
funny dialogue delivered by a brilliant
ensemble cast gripping action with a
gorgeous jazz score that's the best I've
heard in years it's nothing less than a
modern masterpiece I mean how did you I
know you just said it it it could bring
a 2d write but like how did you feel
after twenty years of hoping to make
this to read something like that from
none other than the legendary Ken Burns
I mean what what happened were you
dumbstruck were you yeah yeah I am I
mean it's a funny thing when you finish
a thing you go through you go through
these you start to sort of amass
data points on how is it actually
landing you know and you uh show it to
people you respect and you show it to
some friends and you you know you you I
was starting to get a happy sense of
slow you know confidence that it that it
was working as a film that it that it
was doing what I wanted it to do and
that people were just with at least
engaged with the character in some
measure of the way that I that I had
been engaged with him right I I think my
first like very very very very first
thing that I really was holding my
breath on was in a way did I do
Lionel Justice you know did I do Lee
thumbs great character a basic honorable
you know reinterpretation and that that
seemed to me to be working and Jonathan
I was very very nervous showing the film
to Jonathan and when he was really
exuberant about it that that sent me
into what I'd call a kind of happy
relief and but I think that what can
what can get sat that's it gets at a
deeper level of satisfaction is that he
it's more what you read in the beginning
it at a certain point you kind of
there's the there's the there's the hope
that you can craft something in a way
that works a kind of magic on people
just as a there's a piece of cinema
whatever I think it might the things
that have meant the most to me as an
audience member were things that had a
transparency to them where I where you
could feel you felt like it was really
hitting the nerve of your own experience
or even better the collective experience
you know so for me like do the Spike
Lee's do the right thing had a had a
seismic impact on me it was this guy
and directing and starring in his own
film about his own neighborhood and it
was wildly entertaining it was visually
original and dynamic and then it but
then it was about America it was it was
about the toughest thorniest questions
about like race and and how we deal with
each other and what's the correct
response to the tensions that we feel
about living all together and it was
just so so rich sophisticated and most
importantly it it put its so squarely in
the audience's lap it didn't give a
cheap homily at the end it didn't give a
cheap redemptive reassurance in the end
it it basically like insisted that you
deal with with the question yourself you
know and I think a lot of us it changed
almost like the aspirational goal for
like what you're going for what you can
do with a movie and on some level the
thing I've had the most ambition to do
is find things that that in some way or
another instigate that same kind of like
activation you know in we get so much
stuff that's essentially engineered to
make us passive like there's just so
much in the culture that literally wants
us to be a passive recipient of
downloaded cheap nutrition mostly I
think trying to put us in a mode where
we're inclined to buy [ __ ] you know what
I mean I think that and I think the
stuff that activates people the stuff
that really gets them engaged is is rare
and it's really cool when you feel it
when you when you have that sensation
that reminds you like that you can get
actually provoked emotionally or
provoked at
or provoked internet as a citizen you
know it's that's pretty cool and I think
it doesn't mean that it's got to be you
know Adamic or intellectual or that that
it's gonna be I don't know what the
right word is a screed or it can be art
I mean it's like Bob Dylan Bob Dylan
doesn't explain to you he refused to
explain to you what a lot of what he did
was about but you knew you know you knew
you know you people in his generation
they knew what he was writing about and
they knew what he was getting at and he
didn't have to say it and it galvanized
people you know it really galvanized
people to to participate in in their
generations and causes and all of it and
I think in some measure that's the
highest aspiration it's it's the if you
can if you can get people to think about
their own participation in the world
around them that's pretty fantastic I
think you know that man I sent you a
message right after walking out of the
theater I saw it here in Austin at the
violet crown really nice small theater
fantastic sound good luminosity which is
a whole separate conversation but they
they project properly and it really does
it brings up a lot and it communicates a
lot without doing it in a heavy-handed
too on-the-nose literally and it as you
said doesn't offer neat pithy
unrealistic simple solutions to complex
situations but it in not doing that in
presenting the story and the characters
and the universal struggles and
challenges and desires in a very artful
powerful way I think does a much greater
service it's a fun watch but it's also a
meaningful watch and that's that's
really hard to do so thanks I mean I am
it's funny I Phi
you know there's there's the poet Rilke
'he's faint
you know who's i love his poetry and his
work but there's that famous collection
of letters that he wrote to a young poet
there's a bit in it that I think about a
lot he where he kind of says ten years
is nothing to an artist gestation is
everything and it's kind of one of those
things that you put over your desk when
you're in college you know and you
because it just sounds it sounds it's
sexy to think that you know what it
means
yeah weird what I mean I totally do
you're sort of its kind of you you look
you I latched on to when I was young
because I you know you imagine yourself
with that the romantic struggle of it
but then the reality of it is it's not
so pleasant sometimes you know what I
mean but I think that for me the the
gestation on this affected what I wanted
to say and my capacity to even
understand what I wanted to say a lot I
think if I had been able to make this in
2003 a whole bunch of things wouldn't
have happened I think I would have at
that time in my life sort of had more
romance for the idea of like the
cynicism that's in the noir genre right
I think I might have embraced in an
almost like showy way that I could be as
dark and cynical as any noir movie
before you know at my age the phase of
life and then with what I see going on
in the country now I really felt
differently by the time I made this film
like I did not want Faye Dunaway to end
up with a bullet in the eye and the
detective saying do as little as
possible because I think that is not
what this country needs right now
um and I am not super keen on you know
things that are artistically rich but
ultimately really nihilistic like I
don't think we need um I don't think we
need nihilism romanced right now at all
I think we've got we
got nihilistic we've got nihilists
walking into classrooms with ar-15s and
blowing kids away like way way way too
often to be casually putting a sexy
stamp on the idea of nihilism we and I
think and and I and I wouldn't have I
wouldn't have felt that strongly about
that if I had made this ten years ago
let alone 20 years ago you know so it
would have changed that what Ken wrote
what Ken wrote about this and and the
sort of propulsive you know message of
it or I wouldn't I wouldn't have been
the person you know trying to put that
message across if I made this before and
and I and so I'm glad in a way like I'm
I'm I really am genuinely glad that it
took a long time because I think I feel
more spiritually determined that that it
goes in the direction it goes in at the
end instead of into what I'd call like
something that's sexy it's funny because
Fight Club
some people say Fight Club is nihilistic
and a lot of people cite that but I
never felt that about that movie I
always felt one things I liked about it
was the Fincher for all his you know for
all his crusty exterior like that's very
much about what we're talking about and
I think it's about a person who wrote
goes into a romance with a nihilistic
thing but absolutely comes out of it you
know like absolutely recognizes the
destructive the destructive freight
train that he's set in motion and moves
to derail it and moves to grab hands
with a woman and and say like no to that
and and yes to linking up with another
human being and and making a connection
you know what I mean and I think the the
violence in that film is to reduce the
film's message to the exploration of the
nihilism is a pretty weak sauce read of
it in my view I think the I think the
the message of evolution and growth in
it is there and I I kind of feel that
way about this I think that
making models Brooklyn now it's it's got
more of what I'd want to say as a father
even in it then then I then I would have
been capable of earlier I also couldn't
have made this movie in with the budget
that I had and on the schedule that I
had to make it if I hadn't worked with
Spike Lee and Wes Anderson and Alejandro
when you really did the I wouldn't had
the chops to do it those guys made me
realize how much you within limitations
and I think I I think marinating in
their work with them had a really really
big impact on on my capacity to do this
logistically well I've said it before
I'll say it again kudos to you man it's
a great film and I I wholeheartedly urge
everyone to check it out and I do not
take saying that lightly because I
recognize one careless recommendation
and people are like [ __ ] that Tim
Ferriss
so really really interesting and talking
about personal self transformation as an
artistic benchmark we don't trust him
ever again yeah exactly yeah yep yep
exactly right but I do feel comfortable
recommending this it's great and see it
in the theater
that that's definitely recommendation
it'll be great when it comes out on
other platforms but it's it's really one
of those films you want to see in a
proper environment and we have been
talking for a while I know you're a busy
man these days and I think this is a
good place to wrap up but people can say
hello on Twitter at Edward Norton
Instagram Edward Norton official
Facebook official Edward Norton I'll
link to all these in the show notes
everything we talked about a link to in
the show notes per usual at tim doubt
blog forward slash podcast but Ebert is
there anything else you'd like to say
any parting comments suggestions
anything else that I'm missing
no I it was interesting to talk through
this like that because I it's one of
things I dig about your show
I think you as you know I and as
everybody knows you hack the you hack
the process you know better than anybody
and I think I think that I've been
talking about I've been talking about
the thing itself in sort of reductive
ways that are necessary when you become
a cog in the marketing machinery or on
your project but I do think it's very
interesting to actually think back
through the process of a thing with
actual consideration because the truth
is like it's amazing how much you tell
yourself you start to discount phases of
it you know what I mean like it's it's
amazing how much the maybe this is why I
like the mind also like eliminates the
pain of workout you know what I mean
it's like you if we if you remembered
pain viscerally you might not ever do
anything again you know but you knew
it's funny isn't if that the function of
the head has a tendency to I don't know
focus on the positive and some measure
you know I sure like the selective
remembrance yeah the selective
remembrance um and it turns it starts to
turn things into a story and it's I must
say I think you know what I think I
would say is a wrap on it is when I was
thinking about doing this
I talked to Warren Beatty one time about
making Reds which is his his own
incredible you know three hour long
movie about American socialists and it
it's one of the really great films of
that whole decade about America and
about the American character and it's
also emotional it's about relationships
and all these things it's it's a
masterwork and he told me it was he told
me that everyone told him that that he
was gonna flush all his chips on that
bet and that no one wanted to see a
three-hour movie about socialists with
documentary footage from people who
actually lived through the era you know
and and he he just went and did it
anyway and the thing is that when you
grow up on the film and then you see it
got hominid for awards and it's affirmed
and everything you you sort of you you
discount the the the fact that in truth
for him it was a very very very
out on a limb experience and probably
felt very half-baked a lot of the time
and I think it's good for people it's
good for people at any phase of life
certainly I think is good for young
people to hear people who get a thing
done say like it doesn't feel good at
many phases along the way it feels
entirely half-baked
you feel entirely behind the 8-ball and
discouraged and this is an intrinsic
part of it's an intrinsic part of it it
isn't all fun even when you're like
already like you were saying you're like
well but you've had success in this
thing it should be easier it does it
doesn't get easier it's it's anything
that's worth thing's got any actual
merit in it is gonna be hard and the
hard part isn't romantic it's hard you
know what I mean it's right later
it's romantic later when you selectively
remember yeah romantic later but it it
really doesn't feel good along the way
and I think sometimes it can it's nice
to be reminded that it's been hard for
other people when they were getting
things done that you admired because it
maybe gives you that extra little bit of
determination or patience to persevere a
little more absolutely and when in doubt
find a friend like Tobey Emmerich to
call you up and threaten to give it to
somebody else
I think people people people your tribe
the people you trust like sounding
boards it's it's like nobody gets
anything like this done alone it's just
it's you know it it's almost like when
in the back ear book you you see an
author they think things in its names
but when you really when you look at it
as a block and you realize what that
really is is just that's like a tribe
you know what I mean around an author
nobody they just what's more solitary
than writing a book right but you look
at the the network that's around and
author and and it makes them feel
compelled to say I could not have gotten
this done without these people right
it's it's um there's there's not many
things that are that are truly done in
solitude agreed and
a lot of things worth doing not in
solitude also to have companions on the
path and I am could not be happier for
you and it means a lot to have you back
on I hope we get a chance to hang again
soon and get up thanks so much for the
time have a great conversation for sure
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek comm all spelled
out and just drop in your email and
you'll get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by super
fat nut butters I've got two boxes of
them actually sitting within 15 feet of
me in a cabinet these little beauties
are great I've been using them as quick
mini breakfasts that's one use and as
on-the-go fuel for a few months now I
was pretty slammed with this afternoon I
had a Wi-Fi debacle and I was preparing
to record a podcast but didn't have time
to make something to eat or buy
something to eat
but these saved my ass that's a great
use case they're 200 to 300 calories
each depending on which ingredient
cocktail you eat because they're a bunch
of different types MCT meaning medium
chain triglycerides protein macadamia
caffeine etc three to five grams of net
carbs per pouch their keto
paleo friendly and they are really easy
to transfer you can throw in a backpack
or a pocket I love these things the
first time I tried super phat however be
forewarned
I finished the entire box and maybe two
or three days so watch your portion
control and pro tip the way you eat them
you have to unscrew the top and you get
about 90% out of it that way and then
you tear the pouch here it diagonally
not straight across and that will get
you the last 10% or so I suggest
ordering the variety box you can try
that way all five super fat flavors in
one box and you'll get two pouches of
each flavor that way you can also get
15% off your order by going to super fat
comm slash Tim that's super fat comm
slash Tim or 15% off when you go to one
more time super fat comm slash Tim this
episode is brought to you by zapier new
sponsor but not new to me as a service
we'll get to my personal story but if
you run your own business think about
all of the hours and hours you spend
moving information from one software
program to another or one window to
another one social media platform to
another copy and pasting blah blah blah
all because those things don't easily
work together they're not connected with
zapier now they do
automatically my team and I have been
using zapier for years which helps us
with tons of stuff such as just to take
one example connecting Facebook ad
campaigns for email Platt
and you can also as I do
automate publishing things that you put
on Instagram to other social media
platforms saving us hundreds of hours my
team has also raved about safe your
support this is super important to me
which in their words quote is in a class
of its own input and the head is not
paid placement we test all of these
things and if you used a peer as full
paying retail customers
not because we got any type of freebie
so there are tons of examples so why are
there tons of examples there's tons of
examples because Xavier sports more than
1,500 business applications and the
possibilities are virtually endless for
automating processes for getting [ __ ]
done and you may know if you read the
4-hour workweek the third step is
automation in other words not adding
headcount to a messy process to fix
problems but automating as much as
possible you want to eliminate then
automate and only then delegate and
zapier is one of the best automating
soft wares if you use the plural one of
the best pieces of automation software
I've ever come across it is the easiest
way to automate a ton of your work so
check it out you want to try it out or
just learn more go to Xavier comm slash
Tim that's Z ap ier comm slash Tim
connect the apps use the most and let's
say peer take from them you can do a
million things I'll give one more
example you could for instance instantly
engage with leads for your business send
them to a CRM or spreadsheet and then
notify your team so they can act fast on
every opportunity and here's the really
beautiful part and perhaps the gem to
really highlight it's easy to build an
exact solution that you need in minutes
without writing code or asking a
developer for help so as a non-technical
person you can piece these different
programs together in a way that is
customized for your needs and your
business and what is important to you so
you can get the hell back to focusing on
the stuff that you're good at okay so
that's it join more than four and a half
million people who are saving an average
of 40 hours per month by using zapier
now and for a limited time before my
listeners tries a peer for free by going
to our special link zapier comm slash
Tim that's Z API er comm slash Tim for
your free 14-day
I use this program all the time my team
uses this bird up all the time Xavier
comm / Tim hey just one thing Tim this
is Michael from zapier it's pronounced a
beer like happy so that's a beer calm
you
[Applause]
you